[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 y con una invitada de lujo
pocas veces me sentaba al lado de una
doble campeona olímpica y múltiple de
campeona mundial es mariana pajón muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros a ustedes
gracias por venir a la pista gracias por
venir a mi importa y por tenerme aquí
estamos precisamente en la pista de bmx
que aquí en bogotá una pista muy
importante porque aquí a finales de mayo
tenemos la doble parada de la copa mundo
que es el último evento clasificatorio
para los juegos de tokio se repite un
poco lo que vimos con el ciclo del río
en ese entonces terminaste en medellín
en el mundial ahora termina este ciclo
olímpico de nuevo en casa cómo te
sientes feliz feliz de caquetá 9 en casa
es un orgullo inmenso es un plus es un
reto también estar en casa saber que
tienes todas las posibilidades que
entrenas aquí entonces es un reto de
retarte a ti profesionalmente de saber
que puede sacar adelante un resultado
ahí pero terminar en casa ya no estoy
muy bien entonces volverá a repetirse
bien ya y hasta que no termine esa copa
mundo oficialmente no termina todo el
proceso de clasificación youtube y es la
clasificación olímpica se termina el 31
de mayo ahí se definen todos los cupos
numéricos porque los países ya deciden
quién va internamente tienen sus propios
parámetros entonces hasta ese día ya
está la clasificación que lleva años sí
precisamente en esta última parte del
ciclo olímpico ha habido muchos
altibajos en tu carrera
la lesión en 2018 nueve meses sin
competir llegue a 2019 ganas el oro
panamericano luego la pandemia y luego
hace poco aquí en esta misma pista
campeona en los juegos una en los
campeonatos nacionales como ha sido todo
el último tramo bueno sí ha sido una
montaña rusa de emociones y 10
sentimientos y retos del 2018 fue un
gran reto porque yo empecé el año como
núcleos y es cuando yo me estaba
sintiendo medio bien viene la lesión de
la rodilla que ha sido la lesión
siguiente tenido muchas lesiones me
tengo más lesiones que títulos mundiales
esta escuela que más me paro en mi
carrera estuve seis meses sin hacer
absolutamente nada de mi tiempo también
porque lleva muchos años en un ritmo
tenaz o me di tiempo descanse y volví de
espacio tranquila un poquito de funk
para clasificación olímpica y por los
juegos olímpicos pero origen
te dejo todos esos resultados a un lado
ya voy a enfocarme mi mi tranquilidad en
hacer las cosas bien y así fue ahora
cómo te sientes físicamente me siento
muy bien yo creo que ahorita contaba que
creo que fue una de las pocas atletas
que le convino que los juegos olímpicos
fueran aplazados porque me dio tiempo
para prepararme para de terminar de
recuperarme porque no está recuperada
para los juegos olímpicos ni siquiera yo
tener los rangos completos de movimiento
en la rodilla entonces en un reto grande
cuando me dicen bueno tienes un año más
llegó lo tomo positivo gracias dios
ahora ahora entrenar leía darle duro
entonces fue así yo ya me siento muy
bien cada vez más fuerte en cada vez más
segura la pista hacia un buen año sobre
esto último que me dices mentalmente
cómo te sientes teniendo en cuenta que
hay mucha presión sobre usted de los
deportistas olímpicos en tu caso está en
el horizonte la posibilidad de una
tercera medalla olímpica como manejas
esa presión en la presente la pones tú
mismo la presión y es cuando tú te vas
al futuro hay que pasar a los juegos
olímpicos sobre él
unos días ya se cuentan pero estoy
contando lo que estoy haciendo y lo que
hice ahorita entrenando eso es lo que
realmente cuenta las presiones si tú
llegas a unos juegos olímpicos sin
prepararte bien si la conciencia
tranquila existe todo yo estoy en
estaban dándole todo lo que más pueda
para recuperarme para volver a mi forma
para volver a ser rápida fuerte para
volver a ser como mariana lo es en la
pista el momento que yo me suelo partido
ahora y me siento así y esa presión bajo
un montón ya lo que tú te pongas lo que
seas capaz de guerrear la internamente
porque todos tenemos una guerra interna
un diablito que hay que callar de todas
inseguridades usos que todo lo sentimos
pero seguiré ahí se gana y es ahí donde
la presión simplemente está la mente del
bolsillo vas con ella hace parte de ti
las poner a favor y esa lista esa parte
me parece muy interesante porque siempre
que yo hablo con algún deportista de
exclusión a competición casi todos los
deportistas agradecen aa su psicólogo a
su equipo de salud mental yo tengo
entendido que tú desde hace varios años
has venido también trabajando con
expertos en salud mental sí así es no te
hacemos entrenador físico preparador es
un seleccionador que nos acompaña en la
pista en el gimnasio en el velo
pero la parte mental es fundamental y yo
también tengo un entrenar mental que se
llama jonathan bustamante y ha estado
conmigo muchos años y ha creído me ha
estado en mi equipo de triunfo y me ha
ayudado y me abra herramientas para el
deporte para conseguir esos triunfos
para estar tranquila para disfrutar la
vida y un montón de herramientas también
para mi vida son no solamente lo
profesional sino lo personal entonces ha
sido fundamental y muy importante no
hablar de ese tema de la salud mental
cada vez se habla más incluso de tu
paisano jbalvin es el famoso reguetonero
también ha sido en estas personas que ha
abierto más a que se hable abiertamente
de lo importante que la salud mental
así es debe ser algo normal debe uno
afrontarlo con madurez y altura es decir
yo estoy sintiendo esto es normal que lo
sienta tengo derecho pero merezco
también sentirme mejor y luchar por uno
cuando tú estás bien puedes transmitir
lo de los demás incluso lo que quiere
ser tus sueños entonces hay que trabajar
primero en uno para mantener la llama
encendida esa tranquilidad esa felicidad
para transmitir e ir por esos sueños
pienso yo que eso debe ser así quiero
cambiar el tema por algo que pasó hace
poco desde la cuenta de instagram de los
juegos olímpicos' publicaron unas cuatro
imágenes con cuatro vasijas
griegas con cuatro imágenes de cuatro
grandes deportistas de hoy en día
michael phelps usain bolt simón baile y
tú cómo te sentiste como recibir hasta
donde viste tu nombre en medio de estos
otros grandísimos deportistas años tengo
que aceptar lo que casi me haga por un
infarto yo porque yo sigo la cuenta
obviamente yo sigo esperando que pongan
algo cuando voy viendo y veo esos
nombres que son mis ídolos grandes
atletas a nivel mundial y mariana pajón
y joe a uno de verdad que es un orgullo
y no de verdad ese día me motivó mucho
porque como atletas tenemos altibajos
también hay momentos en los que
necesitamos también esas cosas pegarnos
de esas cosas que nos hace sentir bien y
fue un plus yo ya no me creo que haya
pensado en una colombiana bicicrosista
pero enorme paso otra parte y yelena
isinbáyeva de la leyenda del atletismo
rusa pues está un comentario como oye
falte yo y finalmente los juegos
olímpicos terminan también agregando
yelena isinbáyeva un poco ello también
si es normal y yo creo que es obviamente
cuatro de que a cortísimo para todos los
atletas que hacen tanto esfuerzo y que
tantas alegrías
un montón de países y culturas entonces
yo creo que es de esas vacías tienen que
haber muchísimas yo me siento muy
orgullosa de que hayan puesto mi nombre
ahí eso fue muy motivante sí para poner
en contexto a la audiencia de lo que tú
has conseguido en bmx es muy difícil
porque ese deporte lo tenemos la fortuna
de ver cómo compiten el bm que es justo
lo nuestro es un deporte de muchas
caídas donde hay mucho riesgo y
revalidar un oro olímpico revalidar un
campeonato mundial es muy difícil en tu
deporte así es es un reto grande cuando
tú llegas a lo más alto y mantenerse ahí
en un deporte en el que no hay líneas en
el que también hay otras siete
corredoras que el sol sale para todos
que todas entrenando bien para ganar es
un reto grande yo lo afronto es pensando
en lo que estoy haciendo yo sobre mi
bici lo que yo puedo controlar a lo que
le puedo dedicar energía y haciendo lo
que me gusta eso es la mejor forma de
revalidar un título yo pienso que no es
así a mí siempre me dicen vas otra vez
porque para que no te quiten el
campeonato no yo lo que ganaste es tuyo
nadie más se lo puede quitar
tú puedes ganar más es tu decisión pero
ya eso que tú verás te es enorme si
quieres superarlo
bien
pero no es revalidarlo ni ni otra vez o
tratar de recuperarlo no eso es tuyo
guárdalo siente feliz con eso a trabajar
duro si quieres otro pero de ser así
debes pensar así como sientes tú que has
abierto el camino para el bmx en
colombia' personalmente específicamente
para las mujeres porque cuando tú
empiezas de competir cuando era una niña
tú competidas con niños porque no había
categorías bienvenidas de mx finas es un
tema que ha sido muy lindo el proceso
cuando yo empecé me acuerdo que las
primeras competencias que yo iba a ver a
mi hermano competir había una categoría
de mujeres y salían como dos o tres
mujeres mucho más grandes que yo cuando
yo empiezo a competir no había mujeres
de mi categoría e incluso ni siquiera
habían niños de mi edad yo corría contra
niños de 5 o 6 años que tenía 4 yo no me
daba cuenta que no habían viniendo
simplemente estaba haciendo lo que me
gustaba corriendo contra ellos después
me empecé a dar cuenta que había un
mundo en el que no no había ni equidad
minados hay un ganado en la categoría de
hombres y el niño que quedaba segundo
también le hago en el trofeo primero y
yo creo porque yo corrí contra en la
misma pista con la misma bici pero fue
eso fue cambiando
de pasar de recibir cartas a que yo no
pudiera competir a ver qué había más
niñas que querían pero sobre todo papás
que querían que sus niñas frank
bicicrosistas porque no es un secreto
que es un deporte extremo de contacto
que tiene un riesgo y que una niña de
pronto asusta para los papás que esté
haciendo esto y mamá y papá les dio
susto entonces ver ese cambio y ver un
montón de categorías de niñas ahora
campeonas mundiales también con un
talento de locos que de verdad el
talento de colombia es enorme y ver ese
montón de niñas que sueñan y que los
papás crean en ellas de esa enorme
quiero que hablemos sobre un poco acerca
del futuro de futuro lejano por decirlo
así dice que no hacemos todavía en tokio
pero te quería preguntar si tú te ves
compitiendo en otro ciclo olímpico este
ciclo olímpico hasta parís 2024 es de
sólo tres años
te ves también completando ese ciclo
olímpico y yo doy como paso por paso esa
misma pregunta bank en londres yo
siempre la punta verá río ni al dónde yo
gane londres pero fue como muy rápido
todo el río era como la fase de mi
preparación en la que por madurez
deportivo a estar mejor
le dimos la oportunidad y nos vamos a
otro me golpeado por esta última lesión
que tuve la primera que dije será que
voy no voy seria hoy como por reto por
reto el bmx me encanta también me
encanta la pista entonces sé que también
tengo un reto que quiero cumplir en este
deporte vamos a ver yo voy a tokio
esto es esto es mi pasión más allá de a
mí los juegos el vi cuando me definen ni
define mi vida entonces voy paso por
paso dejando que mi pasión sigue al
momento que ya no siento a sadam ali
nace su gusto ese día cuelgo la bici por
ahora firme es maravilloso tu pareja es
francés pero compite con colombia
avanzan pero han hablado acerca de esa
posibilidad oye te imaginas estar en
parís así que me han dicho que no que
quieres pensar en eso pero han hablado a
ti maya estar en parís en tu país pero
con mi bandera compitiendo juntos claro
que sí sí lo hemos hablado incluso hemos
dicho si no fueran parís de pronto la
pensábamos más pero madres porque es
nuestra segunda casa también nosotros
casi la mitad del tiempo estamos allá
con su familia con su cultura en el club
nuestro club es francés entonces tenemos
que estar mucho allá corremos mucho en
europa que sería muy lindo tener también
a su familia cerca
en su tierra aunque tenga otros colores
el corazón del es colombiano pero en su
sangre todavía francesa entonces también
sería fenomenal
yo sé que sería bien extraño un reto
grande para él pero obviamente tener su
familia en la tribuna sería muy lindo y
yo también he leído que te gusta mucho y
te sentido muy cómoda cuando vas a
francia si así me gusta mucho la cultura
pasó muy bien allá en la verdad es una
cultura que es fenomenal en la cultura
del deporte también del ciclismo el
apoyo que hay el club es súper
organizado podemos viajar por toda
europa con un apoyo increíble entonces
si la pasamos obviamente es mi familia
también y es mi país también por decirlo
y me encanta
marian este quería agradecer a nombre de
muchos comunicadores de la prensa porque
siempre que hay una competición después
de competir aunque tengas fatiga y
siempre tienes una buena disposición con
nosotros para responder a todas las
preguntas que tenemos gracias por eso no
sé gracias ojalá pudiera hacer más
avalado fueran muchas mariah no sé
responder a muchas personas es una forma
de volver lo que ustedes hacen también
ustedes hacen parte a nuestro equipo de
triunfo y la amazona colombia'
latinoamérica y el mundo lo que nosotros
hacemos
nuestro deporte y la forma de unir a un
país es eso así que muchas gracias a
ustedes gracias mariana y gracias a
ustedes por estar con nosotros
quédense porque más mucho más en 324
defense 24 puntocom
[Música]